τμετα εξοδηκατη μετωπίζουν το λύδημα θέλ από είναι ότι ότι εγώ το πρόπραμ πυ έγαμα
ίνα ότι εφίαν όλ γαρότι φία όλι γατετι πουτον τη διαδικασ εμκαρτε ν κεκριμενά κριτήρια
τα οποία ανακοινωθήκαν καίνος που πινισόδημα οκτακος δικαιότλούν το φρμοτος που πιαν πν τα παρ
τουραα και δεν εγκίς αρετός παστούν της διαδικασίς και προκαλώ τον όποιο δήποτα να υκεή
όι απει όι ο δμαρχος χάρισε μου πρόστημο ή εβεμβη καε θελν διαδικασία κύρι δικαιούσε
είσαι με στα κριτήρια του δήμου γιατείς έχα μηλο συνταξιδούχος είσαι έχα μηλάεισ δήματα είσαι
είσαι άτομο το ποίο έσις κάποιε ιδικά προβλήματα είσαι πολύ τέκνς τακριτήρια τα αναρτιμέα και
ότι ι δικαιούσε προσκομίζο τα ον τας τιχία θαπάρει την εκτοσιού ενεί ποιος και ανί
θέλω από ότι προσπαθήσαμε να πει ένα έναν όριο και στις πολοδομικές αι ος τις
δικοδομικές γιατί πέρα που λίνο που δικαιούσε έγινετ θέλω από ότι προσπαθήσαμε το ραίζο να
πει ένα φραμος και ένα και να φρένα φραγμό και να και και ένας πούσολας
στο τι ακριβώς φθάρνει το όριο της ασιδοσίας και ο υ πλέγον της της βοήθειας
κάτι άλλο κακάλα ψήματα είμαστε στην κύπρο μικρή κοινωνία ν θα μπορώ ναμε θερωτήσω γράφεται
συχνά πικν γράφεαι ότι ο αντρέας βήρας στη πίσω μέρος του μια λο του στον
προστάπουδήποτε εν εκλογές του σιχτ θεωρείτε να σπετιχημένος δήμαρχος έκανε πολλά ντιν πυ ιονεμπρι στηρίκτηκε
πο πολού στη λάρνακα θέλεις να είσαι εποψηφιο τοοότα και τον πολέο πάν ότε είαι
ότι τους οτόοςες υπολούς που θέλούν νόσ άρα εθαλιψε που αα υποψήφι για την προεδριά
αλλά κινο που το λέω έντημα ούτε στο πάνω ούτε στο κάτο ούτε το προστά
ούτε στο πίσω μέρος υπάρχειτού το θέμο θέλω απω ότι σε τέσσερα χρόνια σε τρία
χρόνια χ τόσα πο λα τα πράγματα να κάμοτες δήμαρχος ς